love him or hate him batfleck is putting
in the work for his upcoming role in
Batman V Superman also he's revealing
all the secrets thanks batfleck I'm Kate
and this is your batfleck tastic news
update Ben Affleck has confirmed that a
solo bat film is indeed in development
in an interview with ewf like explained
that Warner does plan to make another
Batman movie but stopped short of
revealing his involvement it's in
development and right now I'm really
focused on finishing live by night
that's where my focus is and I tend to
be a one movie at a time guy when I'm
finished with this movie then I'll focus
on my next movie and figure out what
that will be last year it was reported
that his deal with the studio to play
the character also included him writing
and directing a future movie for them it
has also been revealed that dawn of
justice director Zack Snyder at one time
plan to put previous bat actor Christian
Bale in the film speaking to film Inc
Snyder explained that casting bail would
have clarified that his film did not
exist in the same universe as
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
in the Batman universe the Chris Nolan
created Superman would have a hard time
existing that's why we did a reboot on
the universe so we could allow these
characters to exist together we needed
to do that to have Batman exist in this
world are you looking forward to a solo
bat film or have we reached peak bat
saturation let me know in the comments
or come find me on Twitter I'm at how
not to draw thanks for watching and fro
your gaming and bad news keep it
gamespot